i think that the risk for the democrats
is they fall
as out of touch with people living in
the midwest living wherever else it is
in this country open door immigration
got brexit over the line
and has destroyed socialism in the
united kingdom and that i think is a
very
inspiring message but it needs a
republican party
that's got a distinct clear message
as to how they're going to deal with the
crisis so they've got to get themselves
organized but with the right message
they're an awful lot of democrat voters
that will vote republican next year
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
british activist commentator
former leader of the uk independence
party as well as the former leader
of the brexit party and now he's on tour
right here in the u.s of a nigel farage
i don't know how we haven't done this
before finally welcome to the reuben
report well i'm delighted to be here
and uh yeah i've come actually with a
very optimistic message
because i know a lot of conservatives
here are really down at the moment you
know
down that their guy got 75 million votes
and somehow didn't win
down about what's going on in our cities
with
you know a deliberate attempt to divide
black and white people which is
horrendous
and down about what biden might do is he
gonna pack the court or that i mean
all these things and my sense from my
american friends
is some of them are down to the point of
being disillusioned yeah
and disillusioned movements pessimistic
movements
don't win so the message i've come with
is this
we voted brexit june 23 2016 a great
historic night
three years later guess what our
contract our contract to leave on march
29
2019 we woke up on march 30th not idiot
not only have we not
left it looked like there was no
prospect of us leaving and yet
we led a grassroots rebellion fight back
we've smashed the establishment we've
won we've got brexit
the socialist party in the uk who were
heavily on the remain side
and heavily pro-open borders are
literally being crushed
electorally week by week and my message
is
however bad it looks actually this
administration are making some terrible
mistakes what is happening on the border
effectively turns every state into a
border state
so my message is don't be down don't get
don't be mad
there's a big chance here for a massive
victory in 2022
and an even bigger one in 2024 but the
right in america
he needs to unite needs to have some
common messaging
just one or two less egos around the
place might be quite helpful
but don't look if we if we could beat
the global establishment
and get brexit back over the line you
can do it so i love the message
obviously
there's something kind of funny you're
coming to america to bring less ego
that's uh
that that's that's a tough one that's a
tough one but
but you're one of the things that i love
about you and we've gotten to know each
other over the years a little bit
we've had a couple gin and tonics
together once or twice
but you're the type of politician that
actually does
instead of just talks can you talk a
little bit about what that is like
because i think most people see
politicians at this point
basically just as bureaucrats who pretty
much just take their money and do
nothing or maybe lock them in their
homes
but you actually make things happen and
that's got to be very different
than most of the people that you're
around often or have been around over
the years
so in june 99
um against the flow totally unpredicted
i found myself being elected as a member
of the european parliament and everybody
was shocked yeah who is this guy what's
this new party
and i remember the next morning the
phone rang and it was a guy who'd been a
commentator and a satirist in britain a
guy called christopher booker
very intelligent man and christopher
said to me that morning
he said nigel after 40 years of study i
can tell you
there are two types of people in
politics there are those
who want to be someone and there are
those who want to do something
and make your mind up young man i was
young then he said make your mind up
young man
which of those you want to be and here's
the point he was absolutely right
the vast majority of people in politics
are there for rank
title position status and they'll do
i mean they'll sell their grandmothers
to to climb the greasy pole because for
them
it's all about career advancement then
you get people in politics who are doing
it
out of genuine conviction because they
believe the agenda they're pursuing
is going to make their country better
and the lives of their people better
and i personally couldn't give a damn
about titles people say oh you know
you're not lord nigel you're not sir
nigel i couldn't care less
about any of that i did this because i
could see
globalism building back in the 1990s
i could see bureaucracy was beginning to
win over democracy
and i was determined to do something
about it so yeah i'm a doer uh
i i you know i'm not here do you
remember when you first saw it when when
was the first moment that you saw
something that really alarmed you
the first big moment was in 1990
when the government pegged sterling
against the basket of european
currencies effectively the deutsche mark
now you know anybody with any economic
history knows all
peg currency systems end in disaster
none of them
through time ever succeed and they've
done it
because they wanted us to join what
became the euro and that was the first
alarm bell that whatever they were
telling the electorate come general
election time
actually they were literally selling off
our country
uh and then there was a rebellion in
1993
there was a rebellion back bench
conservatives rebelled
over a new european treaty the treaty
that turned it
from an european community into a
european union with a flag
an anthem and all those things and i
watched this rebellion
and right at the last minute john major
who was the prime minister
used a motion of confidence to get this
treaty
pushed through and i couldn't believe it
but hang on
you've been telling me guys that if this
treaty goes through
we lose our independence and yet when it
came to it
you decided to put your career you
decided to put your party
above the interests of the country and i
realized then
that the so-called tory euroskeptics
were frankly
a bunch of chinless wonders a bunch of
losers
none of them had a stomach for the fight
and i said in 93
i'm going to do this i don't care if
people laugh at me
i don't care if i'm the only person that
votes for me i'm going to fight this and
do this
as a matter of principle and you know
frankly
that that that moment spelled the next
27 years of my life
did you have any idea the opposition
that you were gonna come against i mean
when i was in london last time
when i saw you it was during the the
tour with jordan peterson and it was in
the middle of brexit but there was still
a huge feeling like
ah maybe it's not gonna happen and maybe
the bureaucrats still will take over or
do some last-minute
tricks and then of course it was framed
that all the people that supported it
were racists and bigots and all the rest
of it
but just the endless machine that we now
all
see that has been so exposed and in many
ways from an american perspective thanks
to donald trump
was so exposed did you realize how crazy
that machine was gonna
be and what it was gonna do to you and
your supporters
gandhi of course fought the campaign for
india to leave the british empire
and to get his independence and gandhi
once said first they ignore you
then they laugh at you then they attack
you and then you win and i went through
every one of those four stages you know
in the beginning i was being ignored
completely when they couldn't ignore me
i think i was the most cartooned the
most lampooned person on comedy shows
it was as if i was like the sort of
patron saint of lost causes
and then and then the moment that it
really changed
was in 2004 eight and then ten former
communist countries joined the european
union
with total rights of free movement and
this led to
millions of people coming into the
united kingdom it was too much too
quickly
it was out of control and that was the
moment when i linked
the immigration issue with the
sovereignty issue the independence issue
and that was the moment that the
establishment turned on me
and they spent basically the next 15
years
trying to tell anyone that would listen
that i was a racist
leading a dark dangerous movement that
harked back
to the 1930s i mean nothing could have
been david nothing
could have been further from the truth
that is what they tried to do and i have
to tell you
in all honesty you know if i'd known
just how horrible my life was going to
be i don't know whether i would have
done
it i mean you know i finished up having
to live with
protection around the clock uh if you
went out somewhere people threw things
at you
and this was the media this was
mainstream media working with big global
corporations
trying to maintain their own
self-interest but in the end
in the end you know you can keep putting
out pushing accusations against somebody
but if you can't prove it it's a little
bit it's a little bit like crying wolf
and in the end
people saw through it but yeah it was it
was tough it was hard
and then you know i was perhaps guilty
of some naivety
because on the 23rd of june 2016 that
moment
where we've won and all the parties
promised
that they would honor the result and
then we saw a three-year campaign
as you say we were told we didn't know
what we voted for
we were told property prices would
collapse we were told
millions of jobs would be lost we were
told foreign direct investment from
america and elsewhere would dry up
we were even told brace yourself for
this one
we even told there would be an outbreak
of super
gonorrhea in the country because the
drug that was used to treat it
came from germany and we wouldn't even
get some you know supplies of drugs i
mean
there is no there is no depth to which
these people
did not sink but the resolve of the
british people
did not budge one inch and i believe
there is a parallel i don't believe
those 75 million people
who vote for donald trump have changed
their mind in fact i think in many ways
probably in their hearts they you know
they feel it
even more strongly and and that's why
i'm on this tour to spread that message
a message of optimism a message that you
can beat the odds you really can i know
you're a pro because you just did the
exact transition i was going for because
there are so many parallels to what's
happening in america right now
and everything that you just described
that the uk has been going through for
you know really the last
the last 20 years are you sort of
surprised that amer
that conservatives or right-leaning
people or anyone that cares about that
flag that's right behind you
that everyone seems a little bit lost
right now that there really is a shell
shock situation
since really i think it started probably
on january 6 but then once biden took
over
and that he's been so much further to
the left than most people thought not
not that i thought but that that you
know the pundit class
thought yeah look i think
yeah obviously the election result was a
shock
uh the events of january the sixth were
unsavory
there's no other way of putting it and
it's been difficult it's been very very
difficult
and yes as you say biden being pulled to
the left
uh biden you know drop even dropping
references to god
which i think shocked just this morning
yeah many many yeah
yeah many many tens of millions of
americans um
i understand why people feel depressed
and down
but look i was getting this in 2018
in the uk in the 2019. everyone's saying
to me nigel
it's done it's finished it's not going
to happen i kept saying to them
no and i i spent that period of time
planning planning the next fight back
planning my next big campaign
because i knew i just knew that once we
got the arguments back
out there again people would rally rally
to the flag
as it were so look i understand it but i
think there is a responsibility
here on american commentators
american journalists american
politicians
you know who are on the center right in
this country they have a responsibility
to stop doom-mongering frankly to the
extent that many of them are
and and i've over course the last couple
of weeks i've met with a lot
of congressmen congresswomen and they
are down
you know they are depressed they are
down well if you're depressed and down
if you're disillusioned if you're
defeatist that then becomes
a self-fulfilling prophecy so i would
just say
to all these commentators and all these
elected politicians
you know if if you give the appearance
of being miserable and depressed
you are letting down not just your party
not just the millions of voters
you're letting down the country i mean
goodness me
you know winston churchill in the middle
of the blitz
when the big cities were being bombed
night after night for 60 nights
and what did churchill do he said we
will come through this
and move on to the sunlit uplands
even at that darkest of desperate
moments
with thousands being killed every day by
bombing churchill offered a vision
the shining light on the hill the
optimism and that's what
needs conservative politicians need to
start doing it
and frankly need to start doing it very
quickly
because the electoral cycles here well
it's almost unending isn't it
but if you you know if there are going
to be big successes
in the midterms dramatic successes in
the midterms
people have got to get prepared and
start planning writing when you decided
to do this tour were you
sort of like oh man i can't believe that
the u.s that i'm going to have to come
to the u.s to give a little jolt to this
thing i mean
where where's the me at the moment you
know as trump is still
somewhat on the outside yeah look i
my first job after i left college was in
1982
working for drexel burnham lambert of
wall street fame all right i spent
i spent 20 years working for american
companies before
getting involved in politics and since
2016
i've been pretty involved in politics
here too you know i came in 2016
trump put me on a stage with him in
jackson mississippi and i came with the
message
that because we'd won brexit against the
establishment that you too
the trump campaign could upset the odds
so so i have a
a huge interest in what happens here i'd
also say this to you
you know we've got brexit we're free
we're away from this bureaucracy
and the signs for the future of our
country are looking very
very good even the imf now think having
told us doom and disaster would perform
us
that we go out but that we're now going
to outperform the french and german
economies all right
but but you know the point is this the
point is this
if we with brexit if america falls
if america falls to hard left socialism
you know and we know that those behind
black lives matter and elsewhere are
dedicated marxists
determined to bring down the western
world if america falls
where does that leave us as brexit
britain because the fact is
the english-speaking peoples of the
world share something extraordinary
between us you know we are
all family we know whether people like
that or not but we are all family
so i don't want america to fall and i i
like to think david
that the message i brought in 2016 did
give people
a sense of wow these guys have done it
we can do it
and i'm trying to come back with that
same optimistic message again so i'm
spending six weeks
going around you know speaking to
grassroots events trying to rally people
and i can tell you
already two weeks in the number of
people
that have come up to me and said boy i
really
needed to hear that i really needed
something positive so
i hope i hope i can do it you know it's
interesting the kid i don't know if you
know the phrase black pill but the kids
are calling this black pill when you
sort of you're red pilled meaning you've
woken up to all of this and then you i
know you get that one
but then the black pill is oh but now
the whole system is so corrupt and so
against us that you just sort of
check out so you're kind of you're kind
of waking them up from that because
that's the path
you don't want everybody to go down
that's what i'm trying to do as well
yeah and you know the thing about brexit
was that it was a long campaign it took
me
i think 27 years of my life but the
thing that i was able to do david was to
build a grassroots
army a grassroots army which i dubbed
the people's army and they were proud to
serve in the people's army proud to give
of their time their money their love and
it doesn't matter how young you are
how old you are if you want to get
involved you can all do something
you can put things through doors you can
make telephone calls and that's why
freedom works you know which is a
non-party affiliated grassroots
conservative organization
for me that's the perfect fit and and
you know
all these men and women who are going to
be running next year you know for seats
they need they need their own people's
army um
and so that's what i'm trying to do and
as i say thus far
i think i'm making you know it may not
be huge but i feel
i can make a bit of a difference so i
think people get the the brexit analogy
to the american experience can you talk
a little bit about
what happened to the left in the uk as
well because your
your labor party really went bananas
under
corbyn and sort of became what is so
obvious to me
is becoming right is happening right now
to our democratic party
so the british labour party you know has
its roots way back
to 1900 you know it was a working-class
movement um it was quite strongly
methodist
as well sort of low church high church
for the tories low church
for labor was kind of how it was and it
was
genuinely a working-class movement but a
but
a patriotic working-class movement the
labour party
you know whatever socialist policies
they brought in post 1945
they believed in the country you know
clement atlee who was the prime minister
that brought in the welfare state
on his door it said major clement atlee
he was proud
of the first world war service that he'd
given
and what has happened to the labour
party is it's become a party
of the globalist metropolitan elite
it's become a party predominantly of the
upper middle classes
people born into relative sort of
champagne socialists i guess is the kind
of
phrase that we would use and their
globalist view
means they're ashamed of saying anything
vaguely patriotic
they wouldn't be seen dead you know with
a union jack or an english crosses and
george
because they they they don't like any of
this symbolism
and on brexit they have completely and
utterly you know turned their back on
brexit in every way
um they lost they lost a special
election a by-election in the north of
england
it had been a labor seat forever they
picked someone to stand
who thinks we should rejoin the european
union i mean they just don't get it
but the key and this is where i think
the crossover could be very interesting
the key is this when ukip
started to pick up millions of votes it
wasn't just middle-class conservatives
voting for nigel farage
no it was patriotic working-class people
living in the north of england a lot of
them in the north of england
and people who believed that mass
uncontrolled immigration
was driving down their wages changing
their communities
beyond all recognition and that doesn't
make these people
racist it makes them want to keep their
towns
their communities their families in some
shape that is recognizable
and they were the people that came to me
and you know
i tell you something the labour party at
the center
basically thinks we're all global
citizens we can all go wherever they
want
so labor has lost its voters on brexit
it's lost its voters on open borders it
scared its voters
when jeremy corbyn who was pretty much
an anti-semites as well
was its leader and the labor vote now is
collapsing
so look at what look at what's happening
on the border you know i'll bet you
if we had dinner tonight with aoc now
that sounds pretty unlikely david i know
but it's probably not happening
but but but you're probably not happy
but if we if we talk to that group
they would not be in the least bit
concerned about what's happening
down on the border in fact we understand
some of the people that come
are given kamila harris books to read i
mean you can't believe it but it's
happening
they don't think it matters and i think
that the risk for the democrats is they
fall as out of touch with people
living in the midwest living wherever
else it is in this country
open door immigration got brexit over
the line and has destroyed socialism
in the united kingdom and that i think
is a very inspiring message
but it needs a republican party that's
got a distinct
clear message as to how they're going to
deal with the crisis
so they've got to get themselves
organized but with the right message
there are an awful lot of democrat
voters that will vote republican next do
you think there's a fundamental reason
that the left tends to always double
down instead of
saying oh something has changed here and
maybe we need to take a look in the
mirror but
instead they always seem to go to their
most extreme
well well i think you have to understand
who's driving the left
you know and frankly follow the money is
very good advice for most
things in life and you know if
if you look at the kind of causes uh
that thesauruses
and others back uh you know they are not
going to change their view
one little bit these are big powerful
organizations
that effectively want us to finish up
with one world government and one world
people
it's an updated form of the old marxist
theory
it's never ever worked it never ever
will work
and frankly i think the elected
politicians
in most cases aren't much more than
pawns in that game they are being used
they are being directed
they're not thinking freely and so all
the influences on them
tell them no don't worry even if there
is some short-term difficulty
because you're doing the right thing and
and for them of course the right thing
you know the kick they get is they feel
morally superior
they actually think they're better
people than we are but none of that
works
when you go out to a good ordinary
decent folk
who work hard bring up their families
and and you know reagan was very good at
this
very good at getting democrats to vote
republican
trump has been very good and and there
is a kind of a realignment i think
going on within american politics and i
think the opportunity
that it provides for 2022 is simply
enormous where do you think trump fits
into that because that seems to be the
outlier at the moment it's like is he
gonna run does he
you know what i've been trying to tell
people is to me it seems like the best
thing he could do is is basically be the
outsider taking the fire
and then you get a guy like desantis to
just run right through
that seems to make sense to me but you
know trump obviously does
whatever whatever trump thinks is best
yeah i have spent some time with him on
this trip um and and that's a meeting of
friends
basically we have become friends um
i i said this is what i said to him
okay i mean and you know i won't say
what he said but this is what i said to
them
i said look we've got the external
threat
of the chinese communist party getting
more and more aggressive and and who's
to say
in in taiwan or elsewhere what might
occur over the course of the next few
years
we've got the internal threat which of
course is cancelled culture
and the threats that represents to free
speech and everything else
and i said to him i don't see anybody
who's got the courage or the charism or
the charisma
to fight those things now if somebody
else
comes along who's got the big charisma
that can do the job that can rally
people in those working class
communities
to go out and maybe for the first time
vote republican
if that person comes along then fine but
you know something
donald trump people like him don't come
along very often
i mean the guy has got an incredible
animal
magnetism and he's shown more courage
as a leader than any global leader i've
seen in my lifetime
that guy was under relentless assault
from day one
just as they tried to stop brexit they
tried to delegitimize him
you know and it never stopped and of
course if he eased back on his policies
they would have eased back on the
pressure but he didn't he's got the
courage of a lion now look
he's got his faults of course he has
we've all got our faults
but but you know in his heart does he
and
with his instincts does he stand for the
right things i truly believe that he
does so
you know let's see what happens you know
as as as the next couple of years
roll out uh but i do you know what when
i saw him
uh he's lost a lot of weight he's
playing loads of golf
taking loads of exercise he looks
younger than he looked in 2016.
i mean most american presidents age i
mean obama and co
yeah you never see them greying before
your eyes
and the fact that he's going to be 78
next time real well who knows but god
willing
if he's in the same kind of shape that
he's in now
there's nothing to stop him from doing
it and i the other point here that's
worth you know mentioning
i went to i think it was eight of the
rallies in the run-up
to the november election all over
america i
want to tell you something i've never
seen enthusiasm
i've never ever seen anything like it
they
admire this man they love this man
and and i would say to you know those
those in a position of power within the
party
if you really think you can find someone
better than this
well good luck you know it's kind of
funny because i remember when
when i met you for breakfast one morning
and we took a picture and i posted the
picture
and then people were saying oh look
you're with that racist that racist and
meanwhile
we sat there for two hours we talked
about freedom we talked about liberty
all this stuff
and it's very similar to going to a
trump rally when i started
going to those rallies and i'm thinking
oh am i going to see these racists here
or something like that
and it's the happiest most joyful people
who in many cases are not political at
all they're just there because
they want to express some level of
freedom something like that
yeah no absolutely i mean this has been
a constant attempt for the left to
tarnish us with this racism word
and it just doesn't work anymore the
real racists
are actually those behind black lives
matter and i really mean that i really
mean that
you know when martin luther king said
in that amazing speech and what i mean
what an orator
the guy was but when he said i want my
four children
to be judged not for the color of their
skin
but by the content of their character
and now what's happening
through blm and elsewhere is we are
dividing people up
into different groups dividing them up
on the grounds of race
ethnicity gender whatever else it may be
and that is
disastrous that is destructive that is
the real racism
and i loathe it and i want to live in a
country
where everybody is treated exactly
the same because if you start giving
special
privileges to certain groups you then
automatically alienate other groups
who feel left out a free fair society
would have equality of opportunity for
all
and of course i condemn and loathe
racism
and yes there are some there is a fringe
on the extreme right
who i think we should simply they would
have nothing to do with whatsoever
but you're quite right you know whether
it was my ukip supporters my brexit
party supporters
trump supporters at the rallies these
are very very good
decent people and the more mainstream
media
you know or hillary clinton point
fingers at them and call them
deplorable or ignorant or stupid the
greater their resolve
to fight back what do you make about how
the the blm
movement some of the antifa stuff that
now that is being exported i mean you
guys are seeing some of that on the
streets of london now and it's happening
in other western countries as well
you know i mean within 24 hours of the
death of george floyd within 24 hours
there were riots in the streets of
london so don't tell me
this was a spontaneous outpouring this
was all planned
they've been waiting for the opportunity
and i was disgusted
i mean to see the cenotaph in london the
monument
to one and a half million dead fighting
fighting for liberty in two world wars
to see that desecrated
to see the churchill statue repeatedly
desecrated
and what stunned me was to see british
police officers taking the knee
in the streets and your police officers
and all these officers don't even have
guns
uh they don't but some do some do some
do but i think we're gonna have to
that's a policy that we'll need to
change no question about that but
but to take the knee and i was going on
uk tv and radio and writing say to
everybody
understand what this is if this
organization was genuinely
about equality genuinely about getting
rid of racial prejudice
i'd have no problem with it whatsoever
but the truth of it is
and you've already got to read their
website
they tell you they're in a vowedly
marxist organization
intent on defunding the police bringing
down western capitalism
and for a new marxist order to take its
place
that is what they're doing they are
trying to destroy us and yet
i've been horrified on both sides of the
pond to see
big corporations you know trying to say
wonderful things about them
i even saw saint john's church opposite
the white house
i was there yesterday and they got a
black lives matter poster
what is going on don't people realize
this is a bad
dangerous organization so i i you know
these are things that really grieve me
and it's the lack of courage
of enough people to stand up and tell
the truth for fear
of being called racist so with that all
in mind what do you think is going to
happen with this mayoral race
in in london because it looks it looks a
little
messy at the moment well
one of the things that has has changed
politics
the united kingdom um has been postal
voting early mail out voting
we've seen it abused again and again and
again
there is no country in which this is
safe and i was i was trying to warn
america
this time last year that if you went
down this route you know the left will
always win at this
because you see if you think you're
morally superior
cheating is quite an easy thing to do
whereas our side
just asks i won't she and i'm pleased to
say
that really but but you're never going
to win the one country
that's got this right is france now the
french
the french don't get much right in my
opinion but
but the one thing they've got right
they've seen how open
postal voting is to fraud intimidation
and abuse
and they've banned it completely so do
you know what they do in france
if you want to vote in france i'll tell
you what happens you go along to the
local hall
you show your identification you're
given a piece of paper
you go into a polling booth in secrecy
you put a cross next to the candidate or
party you prefer
and after that there are no voting
machines used there's no need for those
they're manually counted they're put in
piles and totaled up and that is free
and open democracy
there's a big lesson we can learn from
it now what khan has got going for him
in london is they've signed up vast
numbers
of the muslim population to these postal
votes
and i look i know that in those
communities
you know the women are signed up for
postal votes but do you actually think
they ever
ever ever get the chance to exercise
that of course they don't
i i once saw i once saw a box
a vote box being emptied onto the table
at a count in a place called oldham in
the north of england
and unbelievably of the of the thousand
to say ballots
that were in that box the percentage
that were voting for labor
was 100
that is literally impossible so you know
that that is what keeping sadiq khan
holding on in london is the power of
that postal vote
uh but even in london which has been the
great
labour stronghold even there the party
is now on
it is seriously what do you think of my
friend lawrence fox you think he has a
chance to actually
from a liberal a true liberal
perspective do you think he has a chance
to to fight off the progressive
movement onslaught look look i
i admire lawrence i like lawrence i mean
you know
he's a great guy and the next time
you're in london we'll go out together
you know he's
he is a great guy to be with um
starting new political movements from
scratch
you know a little something about this i
mean i mean it's done
you know it took me so many years
to get ukip said i mean in the end we
had 400 chapters around the country
millions of supporters but it doesn't
happen overnight
now the things that lawrence is battling
for are fundamentally important issues
you know it is it is about the
relationship
between the individual and the state and
this is something that we've always
prided ourselves on
you know frankly ever since magna carta
but but going all through the years
we've been the freest of all european
countries in fact the freest of all the
english-speaking world
we've never had to have id cards or any
of these things
now with covid we've seen those
liberties stripped away in the most
remarkable
and very hasty fashion so look lawrence
in terms of making the arguments
he's in the right place i wish him well
but if i'm being honest with you
it's going to take a lot of years to
build a movement that's big enough to be
do you make a distinction at this point
between
someone that would say they're an old
school liberal and a conservative does
that even
is there is there any distinction worth
mentioning at this point
well i mean it's a funny thing isn't it
you know i mean if
if if you'd said to me 20 years ago
nigel where are you
on the left right spectrum i'd have
called myself a gladstone liberal
you know gladstone was a liberal prime
minister back in the
back in the 19th century but one who
believed in freedom of the individual
uh you know believed in the country um a
jfk democrat from our perspective
basically
yeah yeah i have to say i've stopped
using that word
i i you know classical liberalism you
know
if you go to the oxford union uh you
know and debate with some of the
brightest students in the world
maybe there you can talk about classical
liberalism if you try and talk about
classical liberalism to anybody else
they sort of you know if they're
conservatives just go mad because they
because
because the word liberal now now means
illiberal
the liberals want to ban everything the
liberals want to control everything
the liberals don't even believe in free
speech so yeah classical liberalism i'm
afraid
is only for the debating chamber i get
it i wrote a book defending it but i
i hear ya i hear you uh you mentioned
you mentioned the lockdowns
um you've had some difference of opinion
with boris johnson on this
where are you guys at with lockdowns
right now is it is it vastly different
in the cities versus
the the suburbs well
the truth of it is that boris johnson's
government were painfully slow
to address the issue when it first came
to us you know 18 million people
flew into the united kingdom during the
first months of covid19
without a single person even being asked
to take a test
uh you know so we we we directly
imported this
when the government then did decide it
was going to do something
and lock us down the truth of it is
they've taken it way too far
at the moment we're 50 percent locked
down still i mean even though
covid deaths now are in single figures
every day right
single figures every day on many days
the number of road deaths will be bigger
than the number of cobia deaths
and suicides on a lot of days will be
bigger
than cobia deaths you can go to a pub
but you can't drink inside you have to
drink outside
which at this time of the year in
england isn't very appealing
you can get you can go to a restaurant
but you can't eat inside
you have to eat outside non-essential
shops
are back open but the damage that's been
done to them by amazon is just
incalculable because that's where we
finished up with this you know i
couldn't go
say i wanted to buy a pair of trainers
for my kids i couldn't go to the local
market town
and buy them because the shop was closed
i had to order them
through amazon online and this is one of
the great sadnesses it's the little
people
that have been so it's the self-employed
and little people that have been hurt
and of course the public sector oh they
love it
i mean this is fantastic for them
they're being paid to sit at home and
drink beer
without without any threat to their jobs
so it's big business
and and big government has benefited
from this uh
so look we're frankly we should have
eased up a long time ago
but i will say this
boris despite everything and despite his
own personal difficulties of which he's
got many
yeah i mean it really is a i mean none
of us live none of us have ever lived
perfect lives but gosh
his is very very complicated to say the
least
uh despite all of that there's been one
huge
success and it's this it's the vaccine
rollout
okay so as members of the european union
we were part of the european medicines
agency and the european measures agency
through an unelected european
commissioner was to make the decision in
any pandemic
as to what should be done we left the
european
medicines agency with brexit and the
guardian
and others said this proved that brexit
was a death cult
because we'd left the euro yeah because
we'd left the all-embracing arms
of this big unelected government and the
truth of it is the one thing they have
got
spectacularly right they handed this job
to a woman from private equity who in
six months
put in place a system as opposed to the
eu
where a woman from cyprus who nobody had
ever heard of
who nobody ever voted for with a degree
in psychology
and no other life achievements that i
could discern
has made an absolute complete and utter
mess of it so you know basically
basically we vaccinated you know three
four five
times the number of people that our
european counterparts have
and that is being seen as a you know by
the way if you don't want to take the
vaccine
nobody should force you to take the
vaccine but but but basically
people over 50 people are overweight
people who've got diabetes
you know in vast numbers they have gone
to get the vaccine
and it kind of proves whether you're
pro-vaccine or not
it kind of proves that we're better off
outside the european union
we're better off making our own
decisions
and the approval rating for brexit is
now
17 yeah so i saw that this morning
i mean that's that's actually incredible
so to you that must be like
the the the true reward of this thing
that when push came to shove not only
did you get it there
but then in the you know year or so
since people are actually going oh there
was a reason
for this and the country didn't collapse
and racists aren't running in the
streets and everything else
yeah david i could not be happier
you know how many people how many people
set out with a massive life ambition
and actually achieve it and i have and i
can't i mean frankly
i almost can't believe my luck i mean
now
now look well well there's always a bit
of luck but but
but but now i can go to the local
supermarket
a walk around and get some shopping
without a security guard
and people are coming up and say well
done nige we love it so things have
changed in it
i mean you know all that abuse that i
took for year after year after year
you know the game has changed we're out
in terms of geopolitics
brexit is the biggest change since the
fall of the berlin wall
over 30 years ago it's the first you
know
literally the first big kickback against
globalism
and i'm optimistic that other european
countries in time
will follow us so speaking of other
european countries do you sense that
some of the eastern european countries
that are doing more on borders right now
that seem to be
fighting a lot of the critical race
theory stuff not allowing
some of the gender stuff into the system
do you sense that they're better set up
to fight this stuff than say the uk and
the
and america because they were communist
countries and
more recently and they sort of get the
bad stuff that could be on the horizon
is that
is that really why they're setting up
well i'm talking specifically about
poland and some of the countries over
there
yeah i mean have us have a five-minute
study
of the history of poland in the 20th
century it is a desperate
desperate history you know i mean not
not just communists but nazis invaded i
mean the whole thing
was so bloody so awful and of course the
tragedy in 1945
that you know as churchill very much
predicted in that speech at fulton that
we finished up with an iron curtain
as he named it down the center of europe
uh you know these polls
the reason they joined the european
union is because
it was sold in a job lot with nato
now if i was a poll i would absolutely
want to be a member so
you know for every reason but now the
debate that's going
on in poland and in hungary is
if unelected bureaucrats in brussels are
telling
us who we should appoint uh to court
positions
what decisions we should make on gay
marriage or other
you know very important social issues
the argument's now
resurfacing well hey what's the
difference between this
and living under the soviet union and
you're right about their culture
their identity and indeed their
christianity
you know christianity is very very
strong
in those two countries that i've
mentioned um and
and i think everything the european
union does uh continues to alienate
those those very proud countries and i
think at some point
at some point they will not stay part of
this union and the other interesting
dynamic that's going on
is the single european currency the euro
all right means that all countries in it
are in the same
economic and monetary union how can
greece
and germany coexist inside the same
economic monetary they can't it's
literally impossible
for cultural reasons and at some point
in time
greece italy perhaps even portugal
will decide we simply can't go on like
this because
you know they've got the wrong valuation
of of currency
it's hopeless and i remember the late
great milton friedman
saying that if you get stuck in a
currency peg that's wrong for your
country
one of two things happens either you get
out
and devalue or you devalue the country
and you know something greece knows a
little something about that right now
well well since 2009 greek gdp
is over 25 down and
and americans think about that you know
buddy can you spare us a dime
in the depression was a 16 full this is
a
25 full so you know
far from being this wonderful project
that was going to serve all the peoples
of europe well
it's robbing them of their independence
it's making
huge numbers of them poorer oh sure if i
was a german car manufacturer i'd love
it
because the deutsche mark would be a
damn site higher than the euro is
so it's been wonderful for german
exports but no look
i recognized this early on i recognized
that this was just yet another attempt
to dominate everything
and take everything over i i called it
in the parliament repeatedly
i said this is the new form of communism
and of course
whenever i did that 500 of them would
start booing
and screaming and jeering but hey didn't
bother me i mean i rather enjoyed it
and that's and that's what it is and of
course for the globalists
you know for for people here like the
clintons the bidens the obamas
who so love the european union project
brussels is the epicenter
of the globalist project and if we can
defeat that i think
i really genuinely believe we're taking
the free world or putting the free world
back
into a far better place who do you think
is behind the biden thing i mean
well do you think it's biden that's
behind the biden thing that seems to be
the question people say okay is it the
clinton machine behind it
is it the obama machine is there a
distinction but like who do you think is
really kind of
driving this this thing
well it can't be him obviously i mean i
mean look he's just a duffer isn't he i
mean
he barely string a sentence together um
and so he's quite malleable
um and for some of those with a hard
left agenda that makes him quite useful
because he isn't going to resist too
much i'm also told
that his actual work rate you know he's
down to just
less than a handful of hours every day
he's just physically
not up to it and i've been asking the
same question that you've asked
in the last two weeks here the common
consensus
is that team obama still have a massive
hand to play in all of this and i
i don't know enough maybe you do i don't
know enough to contradict this but
that's certainly from those who who
i would judge to be a mono that's there
you remember there was that famous
interview years ago where obama said it
would be great if he could just not be
president but be pulling the strings
from behind that would be pretty
i mean the guy said it himself yeah yeah
yeah well
i think to some degree that does appear
to be happening do you sense now that
you're here in america and and you're on
tour and you're
in the middle of the country and seeing
the heartland and everything that that
america
is uniquely set up to fight this even
though maybe we can't quite see it right
now but our history
the way we left king george the way we
fought for independence in a very
in a very unique way the way that this
country was set up as an idea
for all people do you think is that in
essence the thing that you really want
to reignite
and is that why you've got that flag
behind you right now yes
yes yeah i i you know i mean i'm i'm not
american but but but i have a huge
as i've said already in this interview a
huge self-interest um
and and i care passionately what happens
in this country and you're right
you know when american children were
being taught properly at school
i'm not sure they all are these days but
they were being taught
all about the revolution breaking free
about liberty about the amazing
constitution
that those brilliant minds put together
so yeah i think it is deeply ingrained
within the american people of course you
know through welfarism and other
problems
you know there is a growth of the
leftist ideology but it is still
a small activist minority and what
you've got to do
is to reach out you know there's
something like
30 40 percent 40 who just don't vote
in american elections and yet their
lives are being directly affected
by what has happened we got brexit we
got brexit we won that referendum
because two and a half million people
who literally never voted in their lives
came out because they believe they can
make a difference and i think
if the republican candidates can get
that message out
and it's not just the negative message
but it is genuinely about how
they can make life better for people
you've got to mobilize
those that don't normally vote and and i
think america's history
does lend itself to that yes i do yeah
can you uh we're going to link obviously
to the tour down below but
what are you doing what are you actually
doing on the tour i mean is this are you
just giving speeches are you going up
with other politicians what what are you
doing
no i'm i'm basically going to activist
groups
and in some towns we go through that
might be 30 people
meeting in a bar at other events you
know i'm speaking at events in arizona
uh where that's in a couple of weeks
time where you know
500 of book tickets already and i've no
doubt it'll be a lot bigger than that on
the day
but i'm meeting the people who give of
their time
their love their energy people that
really care
i i'm going out and meeting them in
their thousands and trying
to re-motivate them trying to get them
out of
and when i sit and talk to them they are
very very down
very very down indeed so i'm trying
through the brexit you know the brexit
example
and also the immigration issue to
explain to them that you know
a huge victory may not be too far away
so that's the main emphasis
obviously i'm doing media various other
things like that but but
really this is about getting out with
freedom works and meeting these people
who did such a great job i mean just
look at the house
you know where the party picked up seats
and and you know i've met
congressmen and women who say look we
love this organization because
when we need help when we shout people
keem people
arrive so it is it is about motivation
and it's also
too uh i want to raise an
issue which is most people in and around
politics
think that the grassroots bit doesn't
really matter and it's the least
glamorous bit of politics
but i know from all the races that i've
been involved in
and particularly when we got brexit back
on track i know
that a good grassroots campaign is the
absolute key because remember this
on the left side of the debate here in
america you've got the trade unions
you've got many of the students they
have an army
on the ground and at the moment i don't
believe the republican
party does have one of sufficient scale
and sufficient size so i'm trying to
push that argument that
everybody can help it's no good
just turning up and clapping somebody
you've actually if you believe in this
you've got to commit that you're going
to do something and it doesn't matter
if you're 97 and sitting in a wheelchair
you can still do something you can still
make some phone calls there are still
things that everybody can do
and if you really do want to you know
just to to save your country
from hard left socialism sitting around
and complaining
isn't the answer positive attitude
energy and action do you think it's kind
of funny that you ended up you did the
brexit thing and now you're here doing
this
and it's like there'll probably be
something else that you'll be fighting
for in 10 years
you don't strike me as someone that will
ever retire
i wouldn't have thought so for a moment
no
no i mean i you know i like campaigning
at the end of the day i think the most
important thing we can all do as human
beings
and as early as possible if we can find
out what you're good at
find out the one thing in life that
you're good at and pursue it and i'll be
honest with you there are lots of things
i'm terrible at
lots of things i'm hopeless at but but
but i i've always
i like people i'm very gregarious i'm
very social
as you mentioned earlier on in the chat
we've had and i love going out i love
going out
meeting groups of people and i think i
can do my little bit
perhaps to spread a little bit of
inspiration a little bit of optimism so
no i'm going to go on fighting for these
conservative causes
across the english-speaking world and so
i'll do stuff in the uk
i'll do stuff here i can't wait to get
back to australia uh to do
you know more stuff down there as for as
for new zealand i'm not quite sure where
we stand there given that they've now
basically sold their souls
to the chinese communist party which
should be a warning to all of us so no i
love this
i love campaigning i love life and uh
yeah i'm gonna keep on running well
nigel i love this interview
so i i hope i can join you on tour at
some point in the midst of this thing
we're trying to coordinate a couple
things but i think the message that
you're bringing is exactly
what americans need to hear right now
it's kind of funny that it's coming from
somebody from the uk but but we'll take
it in this strange time so i wish you
luck with everything
well thank you and remember this
culturally the uk and america have never
ever been closer
you know my kids watch american
television taxi drivers here talk to me
about downton abbey
or the crown nfl is now very popular in
england
soccer's becoming popular here in the
usa and
just a final thought on this when donald
trump was on tour you know make america
great again
emphasizing those three words made in
the usa
everything had to be american and as air
force one appeared
on the horizon and the music started to
play that was such a big feature
of the trump rallies what music did we
get what we got david bowie
and elton john and phil collins and
actually it's difficult with popular
music now to tell
whether it's british or whether it's
american so perhaps
a brit coming here giving this message
is not
quite as strange as people might first
think we'll take it we'll take it nigel
farage thank you so much and we're gonna
link everything right down below
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international
issues instead of non-stop yelling check
out our international playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell